quando mi è stato chiesto di partecipare
mi hanno detto che il tema di oggi sono
le emozioni e i sentimenti allora io
voglio farvi una domanda Quante volte
avete Anzi Abbiamo preso delle decisioni
che quel senno di poi consideriamo
diciamo affrettate irrazionali in
generale troppo emotive
penso che sia successo Almeno una volta
a tutti e la volta che state pensando
sono altrettanto sicuro che non è né la
prima e non sarà nemmeno l'ultimo
e in qualche modo comunque tutti noi una
volta presa questa decisione una volta
razionalizzato pensiamo che le emozioni
sono ostacolo alla nostra libertà
d'azione appunto per la loro
irrazionalità no
mi sembra chiaro e oggettivo che
emozioni e sentimenti ci influenzano
ve ne voglio dare la prova però per
farvi toccare con mano questa cosa
Per chi non lo conoscesse Questo è un
saturimetro meglio un puziosimetro e
in breve conta la frequenza cardiaca e
l'ossigenazione del sangue tra qualche
secondo vi dirà che sto male sicuramente
lo percepite anche dalla voce che mi
trema dal fatto che non riesco a tenere
ferme le gambe un po' di belle d'oca ed
ecco qua ho 128 battiti per minuto in
questo momento mio Dio questo male
veramente
Comunque il mio cuore Sta battendo
troppo velocemente rispetto al normale
se potessimo prendere la mia pressione
questa sarebbe alta
e questo accadrebbe a chiunque di voi in
questo momento
salisse su questo palco Perché cosa sta
accadendo
In breve il mio corpo Pensa che in
qualche modo io sia in pericolo che c'è
qualcosa che attenta alla mia vita
Eppure Qui non c'è niente che potrebbe
nuocermi Almeno spero che nessuno di voi
vogliatentare alla mia vita
in generale
lui pensa questo ma è una risposta a
l'ansia che penso che Conoscete tutti
quanti Ecco io sono una persona
abbastanza ansiosa e quindi
probabilmente ancor di più
dato per assunto che ci influenzano le
emozioni mi viene spontaneo pormi
qualche domanda a cui proverò a
rispondere insieme a voi la prima
Innanzitutto è cosa accade visto che
abbiamo un riscontro fisiologico
oggettivo in noi poi quanto queste
influenzino come abbiamo detto
all'inizio il nostro processo
decisionale e probabilmente ancor di più
anche la cognizione di noi stessi la
cognizione di quello che ci circonda e
soprattutto visto che spesso e
volentieri ci pentiamo di ciò che
facciamo
in maniera emotiva come possiamo fare a
metterli da parte si può non si può c'è
un modo per vincere le emozioni Beh per
rispondere a queste domande devo
necessariamente presentarvi colui che ha
scoperto il fuoco
inventato la ruota e costruito Le
Piramidi lo conoscete tutti ne avete
tutti almeno uno il nostro cervello
l'organo senza ombra di dubbio più
affascinante del corpo umano ma allo
stesso tempo anche il più misterioso
è oggetto di ricerca da anni da un sacco
di materie diverse Eppure ancora non non
ci ha svelato molti dei suoi segreti
quello che è sicuro è che è formato da
miliardi di questi qui neuroni che sono
delle cellule bellissime a mio avviso
hanno una forma Stellata dei
prolungamenti a 360 gradi tutto attorno
a loro riesco a raggiungere delle
dimensioni allucinanti ne abbiamo alcuni
lunghi fino ad un metro e la prima loro
caratteristica è quella che attraverso
queste questi prolungamenti queste
diramazioni riescono a connettersi uno
all'altro si mettono tutti in fila e
percorrono e si diramano in tutto il
corpo delle distanze che per loro sono
enormi ma la loro capacità
ancor più affascinante la loro
particolarità è quella di generare e
propagare cariche elettriche e allora
quelle distanze quei metri in cui loro
si mettono in fila riescono ad essere
percorsi in Pochi istanti in poche
frazioni di secondo E questo rende il
nostro cervello o meglio il nostro
sistema nervoso tutto
estremamente bravo a mantenere il
controllo è efficientissimo efficace
soprattutto
riesce
365 giorni all'anno ogni ora ogni minuto
ogni secondo della nostra vita a capire
per esempio di quali molecole abbia
bisogno il nostro organismo per
sopravvivere ci fa sentire la fame la
sete ad esempio
si interfaccia con tutti i nostri organi
interni e capisce Quali di questi abbia
più bisogno di energia Ma non finisce
qui allo stesso tempo deve mantenere il
controllo con l'ambiente circostante
attraverso i cinque sensi Deve
necessariamente capire queste dolci cose
salato cos'è freddo e cosa è caldo cos'è
ruvido e cos'è il liscio
un controllo eccezionale
Se non fosse che ad un certo momento
accade qualcosa di completamente
inaspettato
qualcosa di fisico di tangibile o
semplicemente
viviamo un'esperienza come non l'abbiamo
mai vissuta prima d'ora Ecco proprio
dall'area al centro del quadrato rosso
dai centro del nostro cervello arrivano
delle risposte
a determinati stimoli a queste
situazioni molto interessanti E allora
visto che si parla appunto di emozioni e
sentimenti Non possiamo Non nominare la
paura la paura probabilmente è
l'emozione Regina Non per altro viene
chiamata l'emozione della sopravvivenza
e dell'evoluzione
quando il nostro cervello percepisce in
qualche modo una situazione di pericolo
e la contestualizza con l'emozione della
paura dal nostro cervello viene
rilasciato all'improvviso una quantità
enorme di quella molecola strana lì al
centro che Conoscete tutti in realtà e
si chiama adrenalina
Ecco all'improvviso La pupilla si dilata
abbiamo bisogno di far entrare più luce
di ottenere un'immagine più nitida ma
perdiamo campo visivo la muscolatura
acquisisce tono vigore si sta preparando
ad uno sforzo improvviso ma soprattutto
importante lo stomaco
ti consuma ogni minuto dei quantitativi
enormi di energia ed è in funzione h24
Deve smettere di funzionare perché
quella energia
deve essere alla muscolatura che si è
pronta ma ha bisogno di energia per
muoversi tutto questo agevolato dal
cuore che in pochi secondi aumenta la
frequenza e probabilmente vi ho spiegato
come stavo pochi minuti fa una frequenza
cardiaca un po' più accelerata
conseguenza di tutto questo c'è anche la
pelle d'oca
ogni tanto Si avvertono le famose
farfalle allo stomaco una morsa alla
bocca dello stomaco e tutto questo in
realtà è un bene che accada è un bene
perché questo meccanismo ci salva la
vita
ipotizzate immaginate di trovarvi di
fronte ad un rapinatore con una pistola
che vi viene puntata alla testa Ecco il
vostro corpo reagirà in questo modo ma
in una maniera estremamente più elevata
rispetto a quella che ha fatto con me
qui eppure è la stessa cosa solo che in
quantitativi diversi E allora perché
come mai il mio cervello io non capisco
qual è la differenza tra un pericolo
tangibile fisico reale e un pericolo non
reale semplicemente una paura indotta
dal fatto che averli qui davanti
mi incute un po' di timore non è così
nuovo in realtà questa cosa per quanto
lo sia un'emozione un sentimento questa
cosa la conoscete tutti perché il dolore
per esempio nel nostro organismo ha
delle risposte molto simili sia che
questo sia un dolore fisico o un taglio
una ferita sia di questo si è emotivo
sarebbe molto complesso da spiegare ma
potete capirlo in un attimo pensando che
lunghi periodi di stress emotivo
in noi generano delle patologie ci fanno
stare male Ci viene la gastrite
piuttosto che il mal di testa tutto
questo per del semplice stress per
emozioni negative ripetute nel tempo
questo impatto non sul nostro organismo
a livello fisiologico non ce l'hanno
soltanto emozioni negative come la paura
l'ansia la tristezza il disgusto bensì
anche le emozioni positive e ancora di
più questo impatto diventa importante
quando le emozioni diventano sentimenti
il sentimento è un processo che riguarda
l'individuo è necessario l'individuo nel
processo Ecco qui state osservando una
risonanza magnetica funzionale fatta a
una donna e al suo bambino di 6-10
giorni mi pare di pochi giorni di vita
comunque
la mamma bacia la fronte del bambino e
non fa altro con quel piccolo gesto con
il contatto fisico delle sue labbra
sulla fronte del bambino non fa altro
che manifestare nella maniera più
primordiale che esiste il sentimento di
amore un amore genuino un amore
incontaminato l'amore che prova la mamma
per il proprio bambino in quell'istante
e non soltanto in chi dal bacio ma anche
in chi lo riceve sia l'attivazione
vedete tutte quelle zone rosse sono
tutte aree del cervello che
apparentemente sono scollegate tra di
loro non dovrebbero comunque accendersi
tutti assieme il risultato di questo se
Prima avevamo l'adrenalina in circolo
adesso abbiamo due altre cose
altrettanto importanti La prima si
chiama ossitocina ha degli effetti
simili all'adrenalina e non a caso è
conosciuta come l'ormone dell'amore e le
seconde molecole molto importanti sono
le endorfine vi ricorda qualcosa questa
parola
conoscete qualche altra parola simile
vi aiuto morfina o se volete eroina In
poche parole per stringere il nostro
corpo si droga da solo
decide di drogarsi Sì perché
all'improvviso tramite l'endorfine non 7
più il dolore né quello fisico né quello
psicologico avverte un senso di
soddisfazione
enorme di piacere di Gioia non avverte
più la tristezza e sia uno stato
euforico
persistente almeno per qualche minuto
Ma perché vi sto annoiando con tutti
queste faccende scientifiche
Innanzitutto abbiamo risposto alle prime
due domande la prima era cosa accade in
noi le emozioni sono tante spiegarle
tutte sarebbe impossibile però Avete
capito che le emozioni In effetti hanno
un risvolto fisiologico su di noi
succede qualcosa in noi la seconda
domanda che ci eravamo posti Era quanto
queste influenzi Vabbè vi ho appena
detto che il nostro cervello si droga da
solo quindi probabilmente la loro
influenza è molto importante
ed è così importante
che per farvi capire le emozioni vengono
provate da tutti gli animali da tutti i
mammiferi almeno quelle fondamentali si
chiamano emozioni primarie E noi ancora
di più riusciamo a provare delle
emozioni più complesse la vergogna al
senso di colpa Ci fanno capire cosa è
bene e cose male Cosa ci fa stare bene E
cosa ci fa stare male ci aiutano ad
allontanarci da ciò che è brutto e
andare a ricercare nella nostra vita ciò
che è bello ciò che per noi è bello
sembra un po' così un po' banale eppure
vi posso assicurare che è la verità non
sono l'unico che pensa di aver capito
questo e che vuole dirvi questo qualcuno
qualche anno fa un po' più famoso di me
che dipingeva e si chiama Vincent Van
Gogh ci ricordava ci diceva che non
dobbiamo dimenticarci che le piccole
emozioni sono i grandi capitani della
nostra vita e che noi gli obbediamo
senza saperlo possiamo provare a
camuffare le emozioni a negarle possiamo
provare a metterle da una parte ma
sarebbe una lotta già persa in partenza
perché riaffioreranno sempre
riaffioreranno Comunque in un modo o
nell'altro perché fanno parte di noi
perché sono un meccanismo ancestrale che
è impresso nel nostro comportamento
Grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]